One more question that was sent.
What is the the correct response to
somebody who says that it is not allowed
to refute except that you are a scholar?
It is not allowed for anyone to refute
except that you are a scholar.
and the brother asked a question. Some
people are saying before you warn
against anyone for innovation you need
to sit before the judges and the
judgment has to come out that yes this
is before you warn against any
innovation of people of innovation
firstly and foremostly subhan Allah
that's worse than the previous statement
brothers and sisters
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
He said as comes in the hadith narrated
by
collected by
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
He said,
the prophet
he said, "Whoever from amongst you sees
an evil,
WHOEVER
sees an evil
Do we agree that innovation is evil?
Do we all agree?
>> THE PROPHET SALLALLAHU ALAIHI WASALLAM
HE SAID
all innovation is misguidance and all
misguidance is in the hellfire.
All innovations are evil.
None of it is good.
And again if we want the definition of
then alhamdulillah
it's easy for the one whom allahel has
made it easy to understand it's easy
where do we GET THE DEFINITION OF FROM
THE QURAN AND FROM THE OF THE PROPHET
sallallamah
This day I have perfected for you your
religion. I have completed my favor upon
you and chosen Islam as your religion.
So the religion is complete.
THE PROPHET
HE SAID,
"Whoever innovates into this affair of
ours that which is not coming, then it
is rejected. Whoever innovates
innovation into the deed of Allah
believing that it will bring HIM CLOSER
TO ALLAH is rejected." Is that over the
head of anyone here? Is that TOO
DIFFICULT FOR ANYONE here to understand?
The prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
he said
whoever innovates into his affair of
ours that which is not from it then it
is rejected.
Going back to theith
[Music]
means anyone.
Whoever sees an evil let him change it
with his HAND
depending upon your ability.
If he is not able
then with his tongue.
If he's not able
then with his heart and that is the
weakest form of faith.
So
if for example
THERE COMES AN A COMMON PERSON but
alhamdulillah
he learned FROM THE SCHOLARS THAT WHICH
CLARIFIED TO him or her the foundations
of the religion
and they see someone
saying it is okay to supplicate and make
dua to the prophet Sam.
THEY CANNOT SAY THAT IS SH
based upon the saying of allahel.
[Music]
They can't say that
IF THEY SEE SOMEONE SACRIFICING AN
ANIMAL TO THE GRAVE, THEY CAN'T SAY THAT
IS. THE PROPHET SALLALLAHU ALAIHI
WASALLAM HE said
that Allah's curse is upon the one who
sacrifices for other than Allah.
Allah's curse is upon THE ONE WHO
SACRIFICES for other than Allah.
NOW WE HAVE SOMEONE SAYING no
you have to get the judges together and
they have to decide if this IS
where is that from THE BOOK OF ALLAH OR
THE SUNNAH OF THE PROPHET SALLALLAHU
ALAIHI WASALLAM for example
a brother OR SISTER THEY SEE SOMEONE
ABU BAKR
abusing Abu Bakr
they can't say
abusing the companions
is misguidance
deviation
that individual he CURSES THE COMPANIONS
HE'S A STRAY misguided they can't say
that IF THEY SEE SOMEONE saying
the Quran is creating
and promoting it. They can't say that
that individual is promoting
misguidance.
These things are clear as the sun in the
sky.
Allahel
he censored the because they did not
enjoy the good and forbid the evil.
Allahel
he said concerning them
they didn't forbid one another from
their evil which mentioned is evil.
They didn't forbid one another from the
evil that they used to do. How evil
and vile is that which they do. May
Allah protect us from imitating them.
But if I'm continuing with this,
there's a beautiful
we return back to the understanding of
the
there was an Arabi
the head of the
he was
teaching his false and corrupt to the
people
and he was saying to them remember the
they deny the attributes of Allah. So he
was saying to the people in the circle
who was sitting with him,
[Music]
Allah is the all knowing but he doesn't
have the attribute of knowledge. Allah
is the allseeing but he doesn't have the
attribute of sight. Allah is the all
hearing but he does not have the
attribute of hearing.
A beding came and he heard what Jim was
saying and he SAID WHAT? HE RECITED some
lines of poetry, beautiful lines.
HE SAID
this is a bedin
a bedin.
He said verily jam is a disbeliever. HIS
DISBELIEF IS CLEAR TO EVERYONE. WHOEVER
UTTERS THE STATEMENT OF ANY TIME will
surely disbelieve.
He said has gone insane
because
he is describing the one whom he
worships Allahel
as being
the all hearing without the attribute of
hearing. the allseeing without the
attribute of sight. And he went on and
then he went on to say
[Music]
and he mentioned various lines. He said,
"Would you be happy, oh Jam, if somebody
was to say about your father?" And he
gave various examples that your father
is tall. But in reality, we can't
describe him as having the attribute of
being tall. It doesn't make sense. It's
ridiculous,
misguidance, deviation.
Then he went on to say,
he said, "If somebody described your
father like that,"
he said, "When you believe that he was
praising your father or would you
believe that he was insulting your
father and abusing your father and he
was mentioning this is mockery, may
Allah take care of you and be with you,
oh imbecile of the creation.
This is a bed.
Then he said to him,
he said, "Verily, you are a devil. You
were sent to a nation. If they follow
you and listen to you, they're going to
go to the hellfire in a time that is not
so far away."
That's a SAYING
to say
and many of the people because of this
bed WHEN SPEAKING MANY OF the people
alhamdulillah they left
AND
one of the IMS OF THE DID HE SAY YOU
CAN'T speak you cannot refute the bid of
jam until you get all the judges
together and they pronounce announced
their judgment.
He said
Allah sent the bed as a mercy for those
people who were sitting in the circle of
jahab and who left him Allahbar.
SO THOSE THINGS WHICH ARE clear
he says here
will read his words
even though alhamdulillah there are a
big detail for benefit he said he was
asked A QUESTION WE'VE GONE OVER THIS so
in reality if we were paying ATTENTION
DURING THE DURING OUR lessons the answer
to that question would be clear to
everyone who is present
is it permissible to refute if we see
innovation
and reject it.
Was asked
warning against the people of
innovation. Is it a condition for the
person to be a scholar?
He said
who is the one who has knowledge?
He's the one who knows that the
is
and he warns against him.
He knows that he abuses the companions.
If somebody says to you and you're a
student of knowledge, what do you say
about the do you say hold on let me go
get this?
Hold up. Let me come back to you.
He said you say
they abuse the companions
and they possess this, they possess
that.
Clarify to them the state of the
according to your warn against them.
Speak with what?
knowledge and justice.
The reputations of the people of Sunnah
are based upon knowledge and justice.
Not like the reputations of the people
of falsehood which are based upon
ignorance and based upon oppression.
Somebody asked me, it was said
supposedly in a reputation fee,
Hassan has a drone. I don't even have a
drone, but that was a proof to say I got
money.
I don't even have a drone. Hassan owns
the coffee shop. I know who owns it. It
doesn't belong to me, but if you want a
job, I can speak to them if YOU WANT.
RIDICULOUS STATEMENTS. WE'RE LIVING IN A
TIME A PERSON CAN UTTER A LIE AND NOT
DELETE what is requested from them and
that is and that is A REPUTATION BUT NO
ONE ELSE CAN REFUTE BASED UPON EVIDENCES
BASED UPON KNOWLEDGE BASED UPON PROOF
but people can sit back and slander and
lie and fabricate and that's okay.
[Music]
Do you command the people with
righteousness and piety, but you forget
about your own selves? Do you not have
any sense?